strain which we heard about for the
first time from the health secretary
earlier
this week let's speak to ashish joshi
who's been
looking into this this in a bit more
detail for us and actually
important to point out in the chief
medical office's statement earlier today
um which he released before we're about
to hear from him at this news conference
apologies ashley she will have to leave
you to get you later
because the news conference is beginning
prime minister uh flanked on his left by
chief medical officer and chief
scientific advisor good afternoon
everybody and thank you for joining the
latest
coronavirus press conference yesterday
afternoon i was briefed on the
latest data that shows the virus
spreading
more rapidly in london the southeast and
the
east of england than would be expected
given the tough restrictions that are
already in place
and i also received an explanation for
why the virus is spreading
more rapidly in these areas it seems
that the
spread is now being driven by the new
variant of the virus which
we spoke about earlier this week and
learned about earlier this week
our advisory group on new and emerging
respiratory virus threats
nerve tag has spent the last few days
analyzing this new variant
there's no evidence that it causes more
severe illness
or higher mortality but it does appear
to be passed on significantly more
easily
nerve tags early analysis suggests the
new variant could increase
the r by 0.4 or more
and although there's considerable
uncertainty it may be up to 70 percent
more transmissible than the old
variant the original version of the
disease this is
early data and it's subject to review
but it's the best that we have at the
moment and we have to act on information
as we have it because this is now
spreading
very fast the uk has by far the best
genomic sequencing ability in the world
which means we're better able to
identify
new strains like this than any other
country
the chief medical officer last night
submitted our findings
so far to the world health organization
will continue to be
totally transparent with our global
partners there's still
much that we don't know while we're
fairly certain
the variant is transmitted more quickly
there's no evidence to suggest it is
more lethal
or causes more severe illness equally
there's no evidence to suggest the
vaccine
will be any less effective against the
new variant
our experts will continue their work to
improve
our understanding as fast as we can so
we're learning about it
as we go but we already know uh enough
more than enough to be sure that we must
act
now so i met ministers on the coveted
operations committee last night
and again first thing this morning
cabinet met at lunchtime
to agree the following actions
first we will introduce new restrictions
in the most affected areas
specifically those parts of london the
southeast and the east of england which
are currently
in tier 3. these
areas will enter a new tier 4
which will be broadly equivalent to the
national restrictions which were in
place in england
in november that means residents in
those areas must stay at home apart from
limited
exemptions set out in law non-essential
retail
indoor gyms and leisure facilities and
personal care services
must close people must work from home if
they can
but may travel to work if this is not
possible for example in the
construction and manufacturing sectors
people should not enter or leave tier 4
areas and tier 4 residents must not stay
overnight
away from home individuals can only meet
one person
from another household in an outdoor
public space
unlike the november national
restrictions communal worship can
continue to take place
in tier four areas and these measures
will take effect
from tomorrow morning all tears will
continue to be
regularly reviewed in line with the
approach previously set out
with the next formal review taking place
on the 30th
of december second we're issuing new
advice
on travel although the new variant is
concentrated in tier four areas it is
nonetheless present at lower levels
around the country
so we're asking everyone in all tiers
to stay local people should carefully
consider
whether they need to travel abroad and
they should follow
the rules in their tier those in
tier four areas will not be permitted to
travel abroad
apart from limited exceptions such as
for work purposes
third we must i'm afraid look again
at christmas and as prime minister it's
my duty to take
difficult decisions to do what is right
to protect
the people of this country given the
early
evidence we have on this new variant of
the
virus the potential risk it poses
it is with a very heavy heart i must
tell you we cannot continue
with christmas as planned in england
those living in tier 4 areas should not
mix with
anyone outside their own household at
christmas
though support bubbles will remain in
place for those of particular risk of
loneliness
or isolation across the rest of the
country
the christmas rules allowing up to three
households to meet
will now be limited to christmas day
only
rather than the five days as previously
set out as before there will be no
relaxation on the 31st of january
so people must not break the rules at
new year
they must they must not break the rules
in new york it's very very important to
to emphasize that i know
how much emotion people invest in this
time of year and how important
it is for instance for grandparents to
see
their grandchildren for families to be
together
so i know how disappointing this will be
but we have said
throughout this pandemic that we must
and we will be
guided by the science
when the science changes we must change
our response when the virus changes
its method of attack we must change
our method of defense
and as your prime minister i sincerely
believe there is no alternative
open to me without action
the evidence suggests that infections
would soar hospitals
would become overwhelmed and many
thousands
more would lose their lives and i want
to stress that we are not alone
in this fight or in taking these types
of decisions
many of our european friends and
neighbors are being forced to take
similar action we're working closely
with the developed administrations
to protect people in every part of the
uk and of course there is now real real
hope
that we will soon be rid of
this virus and that prospect is growing
with every day that passes and every
vaccine dose that
is administered as you know the uk was
the first country
in the western world to start using a
clinically approved
vaccine and so please if the nhs
contacts you then get your vaccine and
join
the 350 000 people across the uk who
have already had
their first dose yes
christmas this year will be different
very different but we must be realistic
we're sacrificing the chance to see our
loved ones
this christmas so we have a better
chance
of protecting their lives so that we can
see them
at future christmases and
as sure as night follows day uh we'll
beat back this
virus will defeat it and reclaim our
lives but i'm going to
hand over now to patrick who is going to
go through
some of the slides explaining this
decision
thank you very much prime minister may i
have the first slide please
this slide is the office for national
statistics
slide showing infections have risen
again in recent weeks
so it shows the percentage of positive
tests
against time and you can see from july
to september it was fairly flat
an increase occurred during september up
to a peak
after which the lockdown led to a
decrease in the numbers
during november and it is now on the
increase
again so the lockdown brought the
numbers down
and now we are seeing them rising again
next slide please
this shows the levels
on the 29th of november up to the 13th
of december's on the left-hand side is
the
average uh cases in in the last two
weeks from the
november the 29th and on the right hand
side is in mid-december
the darker the color the higher the
number of cases
and what you can see is first of all
that there are some areas that have got
very dark
and here at south wales and in the south
east of england
and that the overall cases have
increased by more than 50 percent
so a substantial increase in numbers
over
the period of december if i just
concentrate now
on the south east east and and london
we'll see a picture which i think begins
to link into the
new virus variant next slide please
so this is hospital admissions per day
in london the east of england and the
southeast from nhs
data from september through to now
you can see a gradual increase in the
number of hospital admissions per day
and you can see a very sharp increase
during december this virus is taken off
it's moving fast and it's leading
inevitably
to a sharp increase in hospital
admissions
next slide please
if we now look just at the areas that
are moving into tier 4 as the prime
minister has just said
which is areas in london the south east
and the east
and look at the number of cases the case
rate against
time what you can see is the number of
cases
increase or the case rate increases
dramatically
if you look at the dotted line that's
for england as a whole you can see
case rate increasing to november
decreasing during lockdown and
increasing again
but if you look at the solid blue line
which is london
and the southeast and the and the east
in tier four you can see a rapid
increase a
very sharp increase in rates
over the period of december so we have
a particularly fast moving problem
with increased numbers in the area gains
at tier 4 but a
generalized increase across the country
next slide please i'd like to just spend
a moment
talking about the new variant
so the new variant and viruses mutate
all the time but the new variant
contains
23 different changes
many of them associated with changes in
the protein that the virus makes
this is an unusually large number of
variants
it's also got variants in areas of the
virus
that are known to be associated with how
the virus binds to cells and
enters cells so there are some changes
which cause concern in terms of how the
virus looks
but on top of that there are three
questions that need to be asked
does the tr does the new variant
transmit more readily i.e does it make
an increased chance of spreading growth
the second is does it alter the course
of the disease does it make people
sicker
and the third is does it alter the way
that the immune system the way the body
responds to it
if it's been previously infected or
following the vaccine
i want to deal with the first question
there are three different sources of
evidence
from genetic studies to frequency
studies
to laboratory studies all of which come
together to suggest this virus
has a significant substantial increase
in transmissibility
and this is also highlighted in this
graph which shows the proportion
of all the cases that were due to the
new variant
so the new variant was first thought to
have occurred sometime in mid-september
in london or kent and by
the middle of november about 28
or so of the cases in london and the
southeast
and slightly lower in the east of
england were due to the new variant
so it had grown rapidly by the week
commencing the 9th of december these
figures were much higher
so in london over 60 percent of all the
cases were the new variant
so what this tells us is that this new
variant
not only moves fast it is
increased in terms of its ability to
transmit but it is becoming the dominant
variant it is beating all the others
in terms of transmission so this virus
transmits and spreads fast
does it alter the disease program
disease course
the answer seems to be no as far as we
can tell at the moment there's no
evidence
it causes a more severe disease causes
more hospitalization
causes more trouble than the other virus
so
it basically looks similar
does it alter the immune response or is
the immune response less able to
recognize
it there are theoretical reasons to
suspect that some of the changes
might alter some of the immune responses
but there's nothing that's been seen to
suggest that's the case
and our working assumption at the moment
from all the scientists
is that the vaccine response should be
adequate for this virus that's
obviously needs to be looked at going
forward and we need to keep vigilant
about this
but the big change therefore is not
disease progress
not the immunity but transmission this
virus spreads more easily
and therefore more measures are needed
to keep it under control
we absolutely need to stick to the
basics
of making sure that we reduce our
contacts reduce the ability for this
virus to spread and that's the reason
that
tougher measures are required to keep
this variant under control
thank you very much thanks very very
much patrick chris is there anything you
want to
to add to any of that and well thank you
thank you but thank you very much then
let's go to questions from the public
and then the and then the media
uh first laura from worthing
why are shielded still expected to work
in 203
as somebody who's already lost two loved
ones to covid this terrifies me
thank you
well laura um i i
your question why shielders are still
expected to work in
uh in in tier three uh those who
are shielding those who uh are
vulnerable
uh should of course take every step to
to protect themselves and
uh laura i hope very much that you're
not asked being asked to work if you're
uh if if you're shielding uh chris
anyone to add
to that i mean i think the first thing
to say is i'm really sorry to hear about
your two relatives who died from this
virus i mean it is a very dangerous
virus
uh for many people uh the shielding uh
patterns are
actually uh being re-looked at
but the the view about uh shielding is
that in the first
wave uh shielding did many things that
were useful but also did many things
that were
actually actively harmful and we have
therefore changed the model
uh of t of shielding since the first
wave
and that includes uh people being able
to get out more in many situations
and also areas around work but this is
something which people are keeping on
looking at
to try and get the optimal balance
between isolating people too much
and isolating enough from the virus
thanks very much uh let's go to mike
from from cheshire
mike from cheshire asks in in the daily
update figures people testing positive
number of test deaths and so forth could
you also provide
uh the number of people who've had the
vaccine um
well mike thanks for that and uh yes
as you've heard uh from me just now uh
the the figure is
that i've been given today is 350 000 of
so far had their
their first uh their first dose uh and
we'll we'll make sure that we
keep people regularly updated on the uh
on the rollout of the vaccine
uh let's go to uh laura kuhnsburg of the
bbc
um thank you very much prime minister
there were calls for you to drop the
plans for christmas
last week just a few days ago but on
wednesday you told me and our viewers it
would be inhuman
to change the plans and now that's
exactly what you've done
aren't there millions of people whose
plans have just been torn up
entitled to feel that you just left this
too late
and you've caused them more personal
disruption and upset by doing so
and can i ask the medics you've shared
some of the analysis of this new variant
but you mentioned that port and down
have been looking at this in the earlier
press conference
this week can you say if port and down
have completed their
assessments of it and professor woodsy
if someone is packing a bag
right now listening to or watching this
trying to leave the southeast by
midnight tonight
what should they do well uh lauren
let me first of all just say to
everybody uh who's
made plans for christmas as i said
earlier on everybody who's thought about
it
all the care and love that's gone into
plans for for christmas
we of course bitterly i regret the the
changes that are that are necessary but
alas when the facts change uh you have
to change your approach
and uh the the briefing that i had
yesterday about this mutation
of the virus particularly about the
speed of of transmission
uh was not possible to uh ignore and
when the as i say when the virus changes
its method of
attack uh we as a as a country have to
change
our method of defense and uh that's what
we're doing
shall i take uh the one that was
addressed directly to me and then
patrick may want to talk about
port and dan i want to put some numbers
out there because i think that helps to
explain why i'm going to give the answer
that i'm going to give but my
short answer would be please unpack it
at this stage
and the reason for that is if you look
at the southeast
if you look at the east of england and
look at london there's been a really
dramatic increase in the proportion of
the cases that we see
that are when we do on the screening
tests which are not absolutely exact but
pretty accurate
would imply that in the southeast 43
percent of the virus is now
this new variant in east of england it's
59
and in london 62 the numbers may vary
slightly but those numbers are broadly
right and
those have gone up very very fast
over the last few weeks so this has
really gone incredibly quickly
they are much lower in other areas of
the country
and then when you look at the rates of
increase in hospitalizations that have
been
the numbers of people in hospital across
the country what you see is in the areas
where this is very very common
you're seeing rates of increase of maybe
36 percent in east of england
34 in london and 28
in the southeast these are the areas
which i'd actually have uh
significant uh numbers of this new
variant
but if you go to let's say the north
west and the northeast and yorkshire
in these areas there has been no
increase in hospitalizations they're
they're managing to keep things down
with tier three and if you look at
the rates of this new variant in those
areas
uh you see uh they're much lower so for
example in yorkshire and humber
around five percent now again the exact
numbers don't matter but the point is
that if you have a lower mountain man to
this variant the rate of increase is
held by the tiers
if you have a very high rate of this
variant then
it is not held sufficiently by the tiers
and it is going up rapidly and our big
worry
is essentially this is growing in two
directions it's growing up in terms of
percentage where it is
so it's getting a higher and higher
proportion of the cases
and as patrick said the chance if
someone gets infected of them having to
go to hospital
or dying at the end of it seem to be
roughly the same as far as we can see
so far as the previous variant
and if they were to go with this new
variant unwittingly
to an area that has a low prevalence and
start
this being seeded even more outside
the high prevalence areas that would be
a significant risk
to the area they went to so that is the
reason we are really keen that people do
not go
from these areas because otherwise we'll
not only see it going up in the areas
it's already a problem
we'll see it going out to other areas of
the country where it currently is not a
problem
and that it was because we understood
this information
in the back end of this week that we
advised you really do have to act at
this stage
because this is this is otherwise every
area of the country will get this very
quickly
and then none of them will be able to
hold things with uh tier three and tier
two
elsewhere thanks very much uh uh laura
robert pescination
answer the oh sorry give me a question
sorry just to answer the port and down
question
um important are looking at this all the
time um
when dates become available we'll make
sure we get it out as soon as we can but
we don't have any more information that
we've shared today
thanks very much laura let's uh go to
robert person itv
and your colleague on sage john edmunds
has just sent me
a statement saying that as far as he's
concerned this is the worst
moment of the epidemic because of the
extraordinary infant
infectivity of this new strain do you
agree
with professor edmunds um
we saw the virus rising
in kent during the lockdown and during
tier three
why didn't you take evasive action then
to close
down kent even before you knew that
there was a new strain and
what confidence do you have that the new
tier four measures will suppress the
virus given that
the lockdown did not suppress it in kent
well perhaps i could just give a
layman's answer uh
robert because i think the the whole
point is that we were
we were very puzzled during uh the the
november the fifth to december the third
uh autumn measures by why the tier three
uh system wasn't delivering the results
in
uh in kent that it was delivering and uh
a couple of other places that it was
delivering
uh for instance in the in the northwest
and
the and uh clearly there was something
going on it's not really i think it'd be
fair to say until
yesterday as we've seen this data on
transmissibility
uh that we've really got the the answer
that uh
uh explains it and today's
action is a is a is a response that that
change in the science that's my that's
my
like my layman's answer yeah i mean is
it the worst moment well i'm afraid
there have been so many terrible moments
in this epidemic this is
another one but i i have to say that in
my own view this is not the worst moment
in the epidemic
and the reason for that is although this
virus is more transmissible and we must
do everything we can which is what the
prime minister has announced
to keep it as constrained as possible
keep it down as much as possible so it
does not spread
we do have medical countermeasures we
have a vaccine already being rolled out
as the prime minister said
and therefore there is a prospect
relatively in the the sort of medium
term future
where things could be quite a lot better
and if you think back to the
the dark days at the end of march and
april not only were the numbers going up
incredibly fast
mortality was actually higher than now
because medica medical treatment has got
better but we had no uh vaccines on
horizon
they were in the far horizon so i think
this is a situation which is
going to make things a lot worse there
are some there are some really
optimistic things if you look
once we get the vaccine out assuming
that the vaccine works against this
which i think at the moment is our
working assumption
and that is you know we really must hold
the line and my view and patrick will
want to add to this
is what we must absolutely do is slow
this down absolutely as much as possible
and the if we can take it down from a
doubling time of every seven days which
it is in many areas
which is really fast if you think about
that compounding up
and pull it right out even if we don't
manage to put it all the way down and we
hope we will
at least then we're not going to have
this skyrocketing number we're not going
to have the numbers spreading out across
the
country and that will give us a chance
to get the vaccine out
and protect the most vulnerable people
so that if it does then escape
what we have is the barrier of the
vaccine to help uh protect them but
that's
so i think you know this is a bad moment
that's the reason the decisions have
been taken by the
prime minister and uh ministers uh but
uh there is at least this prospect uh in
the future
yeah i i agree with that i mean this is
a horrible moment for sure
um i think we should though thank that
we've got
the genetic sequencing consortium that's
actually got onto this very fast and
found an explanation of what was going
on i think that's really important that
we've got that and we'll continue
to utilize that resource in the uk
and we know what needs to happen to try
and slow this down and it's the basic
things i mean
although this is complicated in many
ways in other ways it's really simple
reduce contacts do the basics
face hand space make sure that that is
what we do
to try and resist the ability of the
virus to spread from one person to
another
and it will slow it down and and that's
what we need to make sure we get on top
of as chris said i think this will slow
it down
and we need to make sure we keep a lid
on this it's not a good moment for sure
but it's one that's controllable and as
chris said there is an important
light at the end of the tunnel with
vaccination having started
thanks very much both uh and and thanks
robert let's go to samco to sky news
prime minister this decision will be
upsetting for millions of people so
could you just speak directly to
everyone
suddenly now spending christmas day
alone what
what hope can you give them and
similarly what's your message to people
considering gambling and breaking the
rules
and funny how long realistically do you
think everyone will have to stay in tier
four
is there any chance it's in place until
enough people have had
a vaccine and to the two scientists
is the new strain impervious to social
distancing measures
might the two meter rule and existing
face coverings no longer be enough
to protect people would you travel in a
train carriage through kent tonight
well um thanks very much uh sam
obviously the
these measures as i say will be reviewed
like all the others every
uh every two weeks uh and uh there'll be
a chance for
for parliament to consider them
obviously along with all the other
tiering
questions at uh at the end of the end of
january
obviously people should not uh break the
rules uh obviously people should follow
the
the guidance i hope very much that uh
elderly or
lonely people who are able to form uh
bubbles who have household bubbles will
be uh we'll be
have that consolation uh that's that's
clear from what we've said
uh today uh but i suppose what i would
say to everybody who's
now thinking of having a much reduced uh
christmas
uh of course uh we bitterly regret that
this is necessary
this year i know how much life and care
and thought goes into
preparations for for christmas i suppose
the message is
you know that this is the year to lift a
glass to to those who aren't
there in the knowledge that it's in it's
precisely because
they aren't there to celebrate christmas
with you this year
that uh we all have a better chance that
they'll be there
next year to celebrate christmas with
you i suppose that would be my
my message sam uh to the country
um in terms of the uh the social
distancing
yes social distancing does work it
doesn't work as a yes no
the more things you do the more more
determinedly you do them
the more people do the basics for
themselves all the things patrick talked
about the hands face space things
but also break unnecessary household
links
the more this and every other
respiratory virus goes down and just to
give some
other examples for example flu rates are
down adenovirus rates are down
because they also have exactly the same
effect on other respiratory viruses
we do not think that the current
measures will not work against this
but we're going to have to do a lot more
more in a sense to stand cell it's like
you were cycling up a steep hill and now
you've got the wind against you as well
you just have to do that much more to
actually keep going and that's really
what we're going to have to do but the
actual tools
themselves unfortunately remain the same
tools
and would i go through kent not unless
he was absolutely necessary not because
i don't love kent the kent is fantastic
but because this is not the moment with
this fire circulating to have
unnecessary travel
so only if there was a very good reason
thanks very much uh sam let's get a
chris hope of the daily telegraph
chris you need to un unmute i think
we can see you
can you hear me yes got you forgive me
for that um how old is the police prime
minister do you
think he should be stopping people from
traveling outside of the tier four
and do you advise police to knock on the
door of households that break these
rules on christmas day
and are these an admission that the
tears have failed are we back to
essentially lock down
until march and just for the scientists
and and medics
i wonder why britain has got this one so
bad this variant so bad
which other countries have it and how
does the new variant get here please
well chris first of all i think the
police have done an amazing job of of
uh enforcement light touch enforcement
they've handed out lots of uh
of fps fifth penalty notices for
breaches of the
of the rules but they've also uh helped
to keep people overwhelmingly
uh in line with what they need to do and
that's you know i really thank the
police
uh men and women up and down the country
for what uh for what they're doing i'm
sure they'll continue to do it in the
same way
uh throughout this period but i'm sure
above all i think people will
naturally uh want to do it themselves as
they've done throughout this
uh throughout this crisis the bulk of
the population uh take this incredibly
seriously
uh get it right um and and they'll
continue to do so
in terms of the the question about why
here and and where else is it
viruses mutate all the time so lots and
lots of mutations of the virus around
the world
this one is a particular constellation
of changes which we think is
important um i think
they'll arise for every time a virus
replicates it can make a mistake and so
that some of these things just arise by
chance the question is what advantage it
gives the virus and this one seems to
give an advantage of transmissibility
we think it may be in other countries as
well
we think it probably is based mainly we
think there's a large outbreak in the uk
it may have started here we don't know
for sure
there will be other types of mutations
around the world it's very important
that this sequencing effort to try and
find
out what the sequence is doing how much
has changed
look is looked at at the global level
and we start to get a handle on where
these changes are occurring
in the virus across the world it's going
to be an important part
of surveillance going forward brill
thank you nigel nelson sunday mirror
one for the prime minister um given you
were at least aware that there was a
new variant of the virus out there as
far back as november
do you now feel it was reckless to
promise
five days of christmas against
scientific advice
and even ask chris whittie a question
earlier in the week you were talking
about keeping
uh meetings at christmas time short
without specifying what short was
can you say now for tiers one two and
three whether that should be
seeing granny for a cup of tea for an
hour a
two-hour christmas lunch or four hours
going to sleep over the telly
well no no nigel first of all thank you
very much but
we've always taken account of scientific
advice always
tried to follow it and that is what
we're doing today because the
the science is clearly uh changing and
has changed
uh in the sense that our understanding
of this new virus its transmissibility
uh has been radically shifted uh just in
the last 24 hours
uh and certainly the understanding of
of the people before you uh here this
afternoon and
we we simply can't ignore that and
that's why we're
we're taking these extra steps today to
protect the country
and answer the question you you put to
me um i mean
what i said and i i'm very happy to
repeat it
is to the extent you possibly can keep
it small
keep it short keep it local and remember
the vulnerable are vulnerable
and that is still absolutely the message
so if you've got your grandmother you
really want to minimize the amount of
contact you want to keep it at a
distance
you do want to have the shortest period
you can
because what you really want is to get
to the point when your grandmother has
been vaccinated
ideally when you and people around you
being vaccinated taking the risk right
down
at that point we have we're in a
different place but at this point in
time at this really really
critical and dangerous time uh
pre-vaccine but high
uh transmission i
keep it small keep it short keep it
local
and remember the vulnerable and short
should mean as short as you can
manage with a reasonable social
interaction and i think one way to think
about it is assume you could be
infectious
i mean it's not somebody else's issue
it's your own issue
you might be infectious and that's the
way that we have to behave at this
moment
assume you might be infectious yes it
can't be stressed
too often that you a lot of the
transmission of the
the uh infection is uh by people who
don't have symptoms
at the time and i don't think people who
have still now
fully get that in in the way that
perhaps they they need to it's
absolutely vital i think to the
i think one in three uh in is these
infections are
transmitted asymptomatically uh still
and people really need to
to realize that can we go to uh anime
kylo
of the mail on sunday prime minister you
said earlier
that when the facts change you have to
change your approach but the facts three
days ago were you knew about the new
strain and you knew that infections were
rising
and still you said it was too late to
cancel christmas
how do you expect people to follow the
rules when they keep changing
and secondly another question for you
prime minister have you put
are you going to put any additional
support in place for businesses and
shops that i have to close now
thanks uh well on the just on the on the
uh the facts of the of the science uh
i think we've tried to to spell out this
afternoon uh
what has changed and what has changed is
the uh the velocity
of transmission our understanding of how
fast this disease is
is is transmitted and uh the
susceptibility of people to getting it
as i say nerve tag thinks it's up to 70
percent
more transmissible now than uh the old
variant
we simply can't ignore that uh that's
data that's been in our possession now
for
uh a day or so we have to act to protect
the the public and
obviously anna we will do everything
that we uh can as usual
uh to look after business to look after
jobs and livelihoods throughout the
the pandemic uh and we'll continue to do
that with
uh the the loan scheme with the with
following which uh
the chancellor has now extended uh right
the way through to
uh to the end of april uh we'll continue
to to look after you businesses that are
forced to
to close as as a result of uh what's
alas uh is happening uh they will
receive
uh the uh the protections uh that
we have put in place the loans the
grants that we put in we've put in place
and we'll continue uh with all that but
i want to stress that this is a
uh this is still a this is a race and uh
we still are doing our absolute level
best to protect the
the public uh whilst we know that the
vaccine is arriving
and i'm very very confident more
confident than than ever
uh that we'll get that vaccine into a
significant proportion of the population
uh by the spring and that things will be
radically different
uh for our country uh by easter i've
absolutely convinced that and and
although this is unquestionably uh
a a difficult moment in the campaign
against uh
against this this virus in the struggle
against this virus uh
those fundamental facts that fundamental
reason
for optimism about the progress that we
have made
that remains unchanged thank you all
very much
it's ten to five you're watching sky
news six days before christmas and if
you missed any of that
news conference held by the prime
minister his chief medical officer and
his chief scientific advisor
here are the main things you need to
know it's been confirmed that london
and much of south east england and the
east of england is going to go into tier
4
a new tier from midnight tonight
it's very very similar essentially the
same thing as the november lockdown that
took place
it means that non-essential shops gyms
and leisure facilities are all going to
close you have to work from home unless
that's not possible
the stay-at-home message is reiterated
you cannot
enter or leave a tier 4 area if you're
in it
no overnight stays you can only meet one
other person
outdoors although communal worship will
continue
and that feeds into of course the things
that have been planned for christmas so
the christmas rules are changed
if you are in tier four your christmas
household bubble joining is offensive
effectively cancelled
uh let's tell you the tier four areas
just very quickly because he didn't
mention them in a list form
kent buckinghamshire berkshire surrey
excluding waverly
boroughs of gosport haven't portsmouth
rotherham hastings
all 32 london boroughs and the city of
london
bedford central bedfordshire milton
keynes luton
and peterborough hertfordshire and essex
excluding colchester huttlesford and
tendering
that information will be online on our
website i'm sure if you could double
check it let's speak to our deputy
political editor sam coats who's in
westminster was watching that
and asked a question at the news
conference sam and we did expect that it
was coming
um christmas has changed dramatically
for a lot of people
a somber probably muted prime minister
they're canceling
christmas uh something that he didn't
want to do
for everywhere in this new tier four uh
region uh those regions of the country
across london the south east east anglia
down to uh kent uh portsmouth all of
these areas uh will now not be able to
uh celebrate christmas people uh only
being able to stay within
uh their household uh and the prime
minister
placing the blame uh the responsibility
for this uh on
the uh at the feet of a new strain of
coronavirus that really
uh they've known about just for a matter
of days and the data about how quickly
it spreads
uh only being given to him last night
and today he decided
to act um for me the most important part
of that press conference was some of the
eye-watering numbers that we saw come
out uh the
weekly average case rate in england has
increased by 66
in two weeks they say that's in part
down to the new
strain and in london it doubled over the
last week and the new variant this new
strain that's at the heart of so many
of the cases well that accounts for 60
percent of infections he said
this issue of cases doubling uh in
london
uh over the last uh just over the last
few weeks
uh really playing hard into uh into the
into their decision
um the prime minister making clear that
he bitterly regrets
uh what he has to do i know how much
love and care goes into christmas
i suppose the message to lift a glass to
those who aren't there
uh is that uh they're doing so in the
knowledge that they aren't there to
celebrate christmas with you
this year uh so they can be there's a
better chance of them being with you
next year so uh a downbeat prime
minister
sam thank you uh more reaction just
after five o'clock and we'll tell you a
lot more about the detail
in terms of the science and the new
variant that they talked about in that
news conference
let's hear from sirkir starmer the
labour leader has been giving his
reaction to what you've just heard of
that news conference
well look the infection rates are going
up very very fast and so
something has to be done and we support
the steps the government's put in place
but millions of families across the
country could be heartbroken
by this news having their christmas
plans ripped up
and i'm really frustrated because i
raised this with the prime minister on
wednesday
and he dismissed that and went on to
tell people to have a merry little
christmas only three days later to rip
up their plans and i think the british
public's entitled to
more decisive leadership than that
they're getting confusion
where they need certainty less than a
week before christmas
has this come too late well we
challenged the prime minister on
wednesday about this
and he pushed back that challenge and
told people to have a merry little
christmas and then three days later he's
ripping up their plans and
families will be heartbroken across the
country as a result of this
the prime minister has a habit of
pushing away challenge
of refusing to see a problem until it
later confronts him and i think
lots of families will be saying how has
this come about at the 11th hour in this
way
do you think people will follow the
rules it's very important that whatever
the rules are
everybody follows them so i say follow
the government advice
whatever tier you're in follow the rules
it's very important that we all say that
the government and the opposition but
isn't it a bit unfair to
do one rule and then suddenly change
with such a short time
i think the heartbreak of millions of
families will be
you know you know it made much bet
greater by the fact that the prime
minister
only three days ago was saying have a
merry little christmas
when we were challenging on this now to
say i'm going to rip up your plans
is it a problem that there are different
rules in different corners of the uk
uh whenever you have a tiered system
you'll have different rules in different
parts of the uk
it makes it more confusing but i think
overall the public will be saying
just when we want certainty just when we
want leadership
we've got inconsistency confusion one
thing said on wednesday
another thing said on saturday and in a
moment
where we're supposed to be joining our
families in a matter of days
do you think this is the worst moment of
the pandemic i think people will feel
you know very very upset and heartbroken
by this
everybody knows that after this year of
all years
families wanted to get together to see
loved ones but these measures are
necessary
and we do support the government in
these measures so again
do you think it is too late after saying
on wednesday
just finally my frustration is that when
i challenged the prime minister on
wednesday on this
he pushed away that challenge only three
days later
now to change his mind just days before
christmas and i think
many many families will be wondering how
on earth did that happen
secure starmur there it's tough it is
sad we will talk you
through all of it next here on sky news
stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast for wherever you
are welcome to
safety rage watch podcast for the ones
who want to know more welcome to the
all-out politics podcast
for the listeners
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free
so
[Music]
[Music]
it's five o'clock you're watching sky
news the headlines
the prime minister cancels christmas for
millions of people in london
and the south east we're sacrificing the
chance
to see our loved ones this christmas
so we have a better chance of protecting
their lives
so that we can see them at future
christmases
scientists warned that the new tier 4 is
necessary
to stop a new strain of the virus which
is spreading
fast in other parts of england household
mixing
will still be allowed but only on
christmas day
and changes could be coming in scotland
first minister nicola sturgeon is due to
speak
in the next half hour
a very good evening thank you for
joining us the prime minister has
cancelled christmas for millions of
families in london
the east and the south east boris
johnson has announced a new tougher tier
four that means no household mixing
allowed in kent buckinghamshire surrey
and
all parts of the capital a new strain of
coronavirus is spreading much faster but
the chief medical officer said that
there was no evidence
that it was making people more sick the
new tier 4 is going to be similar to the
november lockdown restrictions and it
will apply to the south
east east and all 32 boroughs of london
that means no household mixing and no
non-essential travel
the christmas relaxation of rules has
been scrapped
if you are in a tier 4 area
non-essential shops
gyms cinemas hairdressers bowling alleys
all will be forced to close for two
weeks
however communal worship will still be
permitted
under tier four however no overnight
stays will be permitted
if you're living in a tier four area as
for the rest of england that christmas
bubble policy
which allows up to three households to
meet up will apply but it's only going
to apply
on christmas day if you missed any of it
let's have another listen
to the prime minister's statement an
hour ago
yesterday afternoon i was briefed on the
latest data that shows
the virus spreading more rapidly in
london
the southeast and the east of england
than would be expected
given the tough restrictions that are
already in place
and i also received an explanation for
why the virus is spreading
more rapidly in these areas it seems
that the
spread is now being driven by the new
variant of the virus which
we spoke about earlier this week and
learned about earlier this week our
advisory group on
new and emerging respiratory virus
threats
nerve tag has spent the last few days
analyzing this new variant
there's no evidence that it causes more
severe illness
or higher mortality but it does appear
to be passed on significantly more
easily
nerve tags early analysis suggests the
new variant could increase
the r by 0.4 or more
and although there's considerable
uncertainty it may be up to 70 percent
more transmissible than the old
variant the original version of the
disease this is
early data and it's subject to review
but it's the best that we have at the
moment and we have to act on information
as we have it because this is now
spreading
very fast the uk has by far the best
genomic sequencing ability in the world
which means we're better able to
identify
new strains like this than any other
country
the chief medical officer last night
submitted our findings
so far to the world health organization
will continue to be
totally transparent with our global
partners there's still
much that we don't know while we're
fairly certain
the variant is transmitted more quickly
there's no evidence to suggest it is
more lethal
or causes more severe illness equally
there's no evidence to suggest the
vaccine
will be any less effective against the
new variant
our experts will continue their work to
improve our understanding as fast as we
can so
we're learning about it as we go but we
already know
uh enough more than enough to be sure
that we must
act now so i met ministers on the
coveted operations committee last night
and again first thing this morning
cabinet met at lunchtime
to agree the following actions
first we will introduce new restrictions
in the most affected areas
specifically those parts of london the
south east and the east of england which
are currently
in tier 3. these
areas will enter a new tier 4
which will be broadly equivalent to the
national restrictions which were in
place in england
in november that means residents in
those areas must stay at home apart from
limited
exemptions set out in law non-essential
retail
indoor gyms and leisure facilities and
personal care services must close
people must work from home if they can
but may travel to work if this is not
possible for example in the
construction and manufacturing sectors
people should not enter or leave tier 4
areas and tier 4 residents
must not stay overnight away from home
individuals can only meet one person
from another household
in an outdoor public space restrictions
communal worship can continue to take
place in tier 4
areas and these measures will take
effect
from tomorrow morning all tiers will
continue to be
regularly reviewed in line with the
approach previously set out
with the next formal review taking place
on the 30th
of december second
we're issuing new advice on travel
although the new variant is concentrated
in tier four areas it is
nonetheless present at lower levels
around the country
so we're asking everyone in all tiers
to stay local people should carefully
consider
whether they need to travel abroad and
they should follow
the rules in their tier those in
tier four areas will not be permitted to
travel abroad
apart from limited exceptions such as
for work purposes
third we must i'm afraid look again at
christmas and as prime minister it's my
duty to take
difficult decisions to do what is right
to protect
the people of this country given the
early evidence we have
on this new variant of the virus the
potential
risk it poses it is with a very heavy
heart i must tell you we cannot
continue with christmas as planned
in england those living in tier 4 areas
should not mix
with anyone outside their own household
at christmas
though support bubbles will remain in
place
for those of particular risk of
loneliness or isolation
across the rest of the country the
christmas rules allowing up to three
households to meet
will now be limited to christmas day
only
rather than the five days as previously
set out
as before there will be no relaxation on
the 31st of january
so people must not break the rules at
new year
they must they must not break the rules
at new york it's very very important to
emphasize that
i know how much emotion people
invest in this time of year and
how important it is for instance for
grandparents to see
their grandchildren for families to be
together
so i know how disappointing this will be
but we have said
throughout this pandemic that we must
and we will be
guided by the science
when the science changes we must change
our response when the virus changes
its method of attack we must change
our method of defense
and as your prime minister i sincerely
believe there is no alternative
open to me without action
the evidence suggests that infections
would soar hospitals
would become overwhelmed and many
thousands more
would lose their lives and i want to
stress that we are not
alone in this fight or in taking these
types of
decisions many of our european friends
and neighbors
are being forced to take similar action
we're working closely with the devold
administrations to protect people
in every part of the uk and of course
there is now real real hope
that we will soon be rid of
this virus and that prospect is growing
with every day that passes and every
vaccine dose that
is administered as you know the uk was
the first country
in the western world to start using a
clinically approved
vaccine and so please if the nhs
contacts you then get your vaccine
and join the 350 000 people across the
uk who have already had
their first dose yes
christmas this year will be different
very different but we must be realistic
we're sacrificing the chance to see our
loved ones
this christmas so we have a better
chance
of protecting their lives so that we can
see them
at future christmases
that was the main part of boris
johnson's statement from his news
conference just about an hour ago after
the prime minister had finished we heard
a response from the labour leader serkir
starmer he said that he was frustrated
by the late nature of this change the
infection rates are going up very very
fast and so
something has to be done and we support
the steps the government's put in place
but millions of families across the
country could be heartbroken
by this news having their christmas
plans ripped up
and i'm really frustrated because i
raised this with the prime minister on
wednesday
and he dismissed that and went on to
tell people to have a merry little
christmas
only three days later to rip up their
plans and i think the british public's
entitled to
more decisive leadership than that
they're getting confusion
where they need certainty we challenged
the prime minister on wednesday about
this
and he pushed back that challenge and
told people to have a merry little
christmas and then three days later he's
ripping up their plans and
families will be heartbroken across the
country as a result of this
there was obviously leading up to this
statement a slightly different picture
across the devolved nations with regards
what was going to happen at christmas
and potential lockdown
since the prime minister has spoken uh
changes starting to come in
in the devolved nations the welsh first
minister mark drakeford who had
previously announced earlier in the week
that wales was going to go into a level
4 lockdown on the 28th of december has
actually brought that forward
wales will go into level 4 much earlier
than planned and only two households
can gather on christmas day itself i'll
read you some of his false statement he
said this afternoon the cabinet met to
discuss this worrying new development
in the pandemic and to hear the latest
advice from our senior medical and
scientific advisers including the impact
on our nhs
the situation is incredibly serious i
cannot overstate this
we have therefore reached the difficult
decision to bring forward the alert
level four restrictions for wales in
line with the action being taken in
london in the southeast of england
these new restrictions will come into
effect from midnight tonight instead of
during the christmas period
this will mean non-essential retail
close contact services gyms and leisure
centers and hospitality will close at
the end of trading today
stay-at-home restrictions also coming
into effect from midnight
unfortunately we must also look again at
the arrangements for christmas
we cannot expose people to the risk of
this new more virulent strain of the
virus
we will therefore change the current
rules which allow two households to come
together to form a christmas bubble over
a five-day period so that they will
apply
only on christmas day throughout the
alert level four period
a single-person household will be able
to join with one other household on
christmas day
while we all want to avoid further
disruption to businesses and plans for
christmas our overriding duty
is to prevent protect lives sorry here
in wales that was the welsh first
minister mark drakeford a few minutes
ago in a statement
bringing forward the welsh lockdown to
tonight to match up with level four
in england lots to get through uh
not least the new scientific evidence
presented by the chief medical officer
and the chief scientific advisor
at that news conference let's speak
first to our chief clinton correspondent
john craig
before we turn to our health
correspondent ashes jossey
joshie um john we knew it was coming
for london in the southeast but it is
still given what we were being told four
or five days ago
a large u-turn by the prime minister
it's probably the biggest u-turn of
many we've seen this year let me just
bring you first of all the reaction from
the
mayor of london sadiq khan and he says
that
london's going into tier four tomorrow
morning these further restrictions are a
bitter blow says mr calm
our city faces its toughest christmas
since the war and we'll all need to pull
together
to see us through this terrible period
please follow the new rules
lives depend on it now as for the u-turn
it was only on wednesday
that mr johnson said inside number 10
i want to be clear we don't want to ban
christmas to cancel it
i think that would be frankly inhuman
and against the instincts of many people
in this country
nor he went on do we want to criminalize
plans
people may have made for some time well
he appears to have done just that
uh he did as saquia stammer was pointing
out uh call him
he said to him uh last work prime his
questions on wednesday
all you want to do is lock the whole
country down call him a one club
golfer um now of course um
the prime minister is under pressure
from conservative mps
led by mark harmer harper a former tory
minister
to have a vote in parliament the prime
minister is resisting that
uh the uh mr harper who chairs a group
of mps known as the
covert recovery group of conservative
mps says the christmas household rules
were explicitly approved
by the house of commons so it's only
right
that if the con government were to seek
to change them
that must also be approved by a vote in
the house of commons in
advance parliament must not be bypassed
bypassed
other mps have backed that this evening
um
it was a really a really uh subdued
somber prime minister muted performance
i mean he looked
as i mean he's never got rosie cheeks at
the best of times the color seemed
drained from his face
there were none of the little quips
we've heard in recent days
but his argument of course was that the
facts have changed
famous john maynard keynes quote when
the facts change
i changed my views um or something
the prime minister was said something
quite similar to that um
it um his argument was that this new the
news the evidence about this new variant
had only come
in the past 24 hours or so he
rejected the uh claim uh that uh it was
difficult for people to
uh uh to obey the rules and he did
appeal obviously to people to break
uh break to
abide by the new rules and his argument
he kept coming back to it was that the
facts had changed
uh the virus had changed its method of
attack he said
therefore we've got to change our method
of defense and it was summed up the
whole thing was summed up very brutally
in just a few words by professor chris
witte he was asked
what would he say to someone packing a
bag right now
to leave a tier 4 area and the advice
very brutally was
please unpack it yeah john thank
you let's speak to ashes joshie ashes
plenty of information
with regards to why the scientific
advisors have
recommended the prime minister takes
this action tell us about this variant
how it's different and what the concerns
are the main
difference with this variant is that it
is up to 70 percent more transmissible
that is
quite staggering when you consider you
have a
a virus which we already know
is easily transmitted from people to
people you have a variant which has been
identified which makes it
even more transmissible and that really
does worry
the government scientists and that's why
we've had this announcement from the
prime minister
today they're talking about the virus
affecting the r number and the ability
for it to spread so quickly that it will
affect
that r8 that our number that we've been
talking about all throughout the year by
up to naught point four percent i think
was the the the number
uh chris um uh uh uh
patrick valens used the the csa when he
was talking about it lots of detail
about the protein structure
of the virus itself which in it for us
that doesn't really
matter the scientists will have a look
at the way that this virus is mutating
and changing what really matters
is how quickly it is spreading from
people to people
and we were given this assurance right
at the beginning that it
it's not making people any more sick
it's not
making people die any quicker but if
in effect what you do is you plot the
timeline if people are becoming more
infected
invariably they will end up becoming
sick they will end up going to hospital
and that puts pressure on the hospitals
and then people will die and it's a
numbers game
as far as the scientists are concerned
but for all of us it's having an impact
on our lives and what they were talking
about is it has now become
the dominant strain this this new
variant
is now the dominant strain in london and
the south east
and it is although in some small measure
in other parts of the country that's why
wales has
made these announcements today it says
it's identified this
new variant in wells it hasn't really
spread to the rest of the country
and it's not having the same effect on
the rest of the country as it is in
london
and the south east and that's why we've
had this tier four
ban on traveling out of the capital some
people might argue
it's too late because most people might
have decided
ahead of the first christmas week over
the last christmas weekend
to leave the capital and leave the
southeast and go and visit friends
and relatives and loved ones in other
parts of the country but that's
what they were saying they were saying
look at where it's spreading in london
and southeast where it is now the
dominant strain
and where it isn't in other parts of the
country we want people to stop
spreading it because if it spreads it
takes seed in
uh chris whitty's own words and then we
have a real problem then people become
infected much more quickly than they
have done during the year
and that creates more pressure on the
nhs people
become infected invariably they fall
sick and some people need hospital
treatment
and people will start dying as well so a
real worry for the government this new
variant
yeah ashish thanks lots of focus of
course on the change the introduction of
a new tier four
for london and the southeast it's worth
reminding you
of what the prime minister said about if
you're in a tier one to three area and
how that affects your christmas the
christmas bubbles that have previously
been announced that's three households
joining together
that's only going to be allowed on one
day christmas day itself
if you're in tier one two or three if
you're in tier four
sadly the christmas bubbles have been
completely cancelled
and you can't mix with any other
household but one two and three
and the christmas bubbles reduced just
to christmas day
if you're watching in a tier one two or
three area we're waiting to hear from
nicolas sturgeon the first minister of
scotland who's due to speak in the
next few minutes actually to see if
there's any changes with regards to
what's happening in scotland
northern ireland as well slightly unsure
about at the moment because they were
still
also under the christmas bubble rules
between that
five-day period next week but um i
imagine that might
be changed as well but we're yet to have
confirmation of that so waiting on
northern ireland and scotland
just for a bit of clarity to see what's
happening there
of course what we've just heard in the
last hour is sure to be discussed on
sophie ridge on sunday tomorrow morning
sophie's going to be joined by the
health secretary matt hancock
and the mayor of london sadiq khan
that's at 8 30 tomorrow morning
and the mayor of london sadiq khan as we
heard from john craig earlier has given
his reaction to the city moving into
this new fourth tier of restrictions
calling this christmas london's toughest
since the war
sky's sadia choudhary's on oxford street
in central london
getting the latest reaction from
residents there sadia
would normally of course be one of the
busiest shopping days of the year
how have people taken this news in the
last hour or so
well look uh we were just here a few
days ago when london was moving
from tier two to tier three which we
came to speak to people to find out
how they found that and i tell you what
when i came that time it took me about
two hours to get here and find parking
space
uh from somewhere near heathrow airport
and now today it only took me about 40
minutes that gives you an indication
of just how empty london already is
ashish already said that
perhaps most people have already left
for their christmas holidays to
different parts of the country
uh if not overseas so and you know you
can see that when you're walking around
here it's empty the shops aren't busy
like they were a few days ago
the streets aren't busy you can cross
the road without even
looking both ways most of the time it's
almost as empty as that
but we've been speaking to a few people
have a listen to what they had to say
it feels necessary the case rates are
going through the roof so there's lots
of people walking around
oxford street at the moment um and so if
if the rates are going up and we need to
go to lockdown
sad but but true fact kind of upset
about it but what can we do
just have to hope for the best and
score by the rooms the number of cases
are going up
so i guess it's needed it's not it's not
great for business it's not good news
for people
but uh i guess there's no way to avoid
it
seeing friends and stuff like that we
will lose out but at the end of the day
as i said epic will help us we've got
so there's this real feeling of
compliance as you can see many people
saying that
yes they understand that the cases have
gone up and so they're resigned to the
fact that they're going to have to spend
christmas
differently to how they planned there's
also this feeling that perhaps they
didn't expect christmas to go ahead as
planned anyway
either that they didn't believe the
prime minister when they when he said
that christmas wouldn't be cancelled
or they're just more used to these
last-minute changes as we've seen so
often
zarya thank you we also earlier in the
day had to date his latest
coveted statistics more than 67 000
people are now known to have died with
covet 19
in the uk as of this morning a further
534 people had died within 28 days of a
positive test that brings the uk total
to 67 075. a further 27
052 cases of covid in the uk and the
total number of cases
is now 2 million just over 2 million
4 219.
this is sky news coming up next we are
due to hear from scotland's first
minister nicola sturgeon
on her plans north of the border after
the relaxation of christmas carnivals
rules in
england was scrapped stay with us for
live coverage of that
our industry is at a complete standstill
what we're looking at is an industry
that is now facing ruin
we can let it die a death in this
pandemic
[Music]
it's unimaginable our british identity
is our creative industries and our place
of history
culture interrupted sunday at 7 pm on
sky arts and christmas eve at 9 p.m
on sky news
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for the early risers as we examine the
story beyond the headline
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free welcome back to sky news
this is live uh footage right now from
edinburgh we're expecting to hear from
the first minister nicholas sturgeon
very shortly she did tweet four hours
ago
saying that after that four nations call
she chaired a cabinet meeting this
afternoon to discuss the emerging
evidence on this new variant that we
heard about
during the prime minister's press
conference nicolas sturgeon said
is currently at a lower level in
scotland than the rest of the uk
but preventative action may be necessary
to stop
faster spreading strain taking hold
so we'll find out in just a few short
seconds
in fact right now there's first minister
nicholas sturgeon she's joined today by
the interim chief medical officer dr
greger smith and the national clinical
director jason leach
thank you everyone for joining us now as
you can imagine the fact that i am
speaking to you at 5 30 pm on the
saturday before christmas
having just chaired an emergency meeting
of my cabinet and spoken to the leaders
of the opposition parties
suggest a serious situation and it also
suggests a situation
that necessitates action the information
that i
and my cabinet have received today about
the new variant
of the covered virus that has been
identified
in the uk suggests to me that we do now
face a very serious situation
it is in fact probably the most serious
and potentially dangerous juncture we
have
faced since the start of the coveted
pandemic
in february and march and
that means we have to take this
seriously
and it means that we have to act
accordingly and
appropriately now the upside
although i appreciate that given what i
am about to set out to you it may seem
inappropriate to be talking about
upsides but the upside is
that if we do act now and if we act
firmly
now we can prevent that serious
situation
materializing and the advantage that we
have in scotland
unlike some other parts of the uk right
now
is that we still do have the chance to
act
on a preventative basis so i want to set
out
clearly to you today what for scotland
the current situation
is i will also set out why
in light of an assessment of that
situation i consider that very firm
preventative action is now necessary
and i will outline to you the action
that the cabinet
has agreed this afternoon to take
now as i set out in parliament earlier
this week covert cases in scotland had
been
falling in recent weeks as a result of
the tough restrictions
that everybody has been living under but
in the most recent week
those cases had started to rise again in
parts of the country
it was as a result of that that a number
of local authorities
were put into tighter level three
restrictions and that took
effect yesterday and a number of others
a larger
number of others were required to stay
in level three restrictions however
notwithstanding that it is also the case
that the situation in scotland
right now at this moment in time is not
as severe as it is in other parts of the
uk
casey's pair hundred thousand of the
population in scotland are around
half the number that we currently see in
england
and around a third of the numbers being
experienced in wales
and our statistics today which of course
were published earlier on this afternoon
572 new cases representing 4
of all tests carried out yesterday
suggests a broadly stable position
so all things being equal while we had
no room for complacency
we had hoped that we might get through
the next few weeks
at least in many parts of the country
without significantly more
severe restrictions being necessary
unfortunately
as is so often the case with this virus
all things are
not proving to be equal last week it was
confirmed
a new variant of the virus had been
identified in the uk
and on tuesday i advised parliament that
a small number of cases of that new
strain
had already been identified in scotland
now over
last night and today the governments of
the four nations across the uk have
received further scientific briefing
on the impact of this new strain the uk
chief scientific advisor
updated a four nations meeting that i
participated in this morning
and the chief medical officer who you'll
hear from shortly has updated the
scottish government cabinet this
afternoon
now firstly it's very important for me
to be clear
that at this stage there is no evidence
to suggest that this new strain of the
virus
causes more severe illness and there is
no evidence at this stage
to suggest that the new strain will
affect the effectiveness of the vaccines
that are being developed or indeed the
vaccine that is currently
in use in scotland and all of that is
reassuring although further analysis is
underway
however there is strong evidence now
that
the new strain is spreading
substantially and significantly more
quickly
than the strains of the virus that we
have been dealing with up to now
and that evidence suggests that it could
be up to
70 percent more transmissible than
previous strains of the virus and it may
increase
the r number by up to 0.4
now it is believed that this faster
transmission
may be driving the rapidly deteriorating
situation
in the south of england including london
and in wales where we already see cases
rising quickly and hospitals under very
severe and growing pressure
now we do not yet know how widely this
new strain of the virus is circulating
in scotland the latest information is
that
17 cases have been identified in
scotland
through genomic sequencing but i think
we have to be
realistic that that is likely to be an
understatement of its true prevalence
right now
so all of that tells us that the strain
albeit that it may still be at lower
levels than in some other parts of the
uk
is present here already in scotland and
therefore it does
pose a real risk to us if we do not act
and act firmly
and while further analysis is required
to establish this
one way or another we do already have a
concern that this strain
may be driving what appears to us
already
to be faster transmission of covered in
some hospitals and also in some
care homes so given that this strain is
circulating we know widely already in
some parts of the uk
and given that we know it is already
seeded in scotland
and is already circulating albeit
perhaps at a lower level
in scotland the bottom line we face
right now is this
if we don't act firmly and decisively
now to stop it transmitting
it will take hold here and if that
happens the very
serious and the rapidly worsening
situation that we see unfolding now
in wales in london and in the southeast
of england
will develop here too and that would
mean many more people getting
covered in the weeks ahead and it would
mean that by
january our nhs could potentially be
overwhelmed which of course we have
managed to avoid at every stage so far
of the pandemic
and if all of that happened it would
mean many more people
dying from this virus than would
otherwise be the case
now to those who will understandably
look at our case levels right now in
scotland and say
this action is not justified because our
current case
levels are relatively low i would say
this
four weeks ago london's cases were very
low
too and now they are running out of
control
and that is what we face unfortunately
if in the face of this
very severe warning we have been giving
today we do nothing
and that is why the cabinet has decided
today that further
action is necessary and that that action
requires to be firm
it is true to say that this action is
not solely
in response to the severity of our
current situation nor even is it simply
a worry about greater interaction
over the christmas period in and of
itself it is
very firmly action designed to prevent
things getting worse potentially
very quickly getting worse as a result
of this new strain
and i know that accepting greater
restrictions on this basis not as a
result of what is happening
in the here and now but to stop a
situation deteriorating
is hard for people to accept i really
understand that
but the most important thing we have
learned through this pandemic
is that failing to act quickly
decisively and preventatively in the
face of this virus
is always a mistake if i could have my
time all over again
i would act more quickly in february and
in early march
and it's important that we do take the
warning we are being given now
very seriously and make sure our actions
are appropriate in the face of that
so my judgment is if we do nothing now
or do too little now knowing
what we now know about this new strain
things will get worse
and be much worse than they need to be
but if we do act now
we have a chance of keeping the
situation under control
while the vaccination program continues
to make progress and get
case numbers back to very low levels
again so that's why we have decided to
act and to act
firmly now the action we proposing that
i'm about to set out is designed to do
two things and both of these things are
important firstly
the action is designed to prevent more
of this new strain
entering scotland from parts of the uk
where we know it is already
circulating more widely and second
given that we know it is already present
in scotland albeit we think in lower
numbers right now
this action is designed to reduce the
risk of it spreading any further here
within scotland
so let me set out what the cabinet has
decided
firstly we are asking everyone to
redouble
your personal efforts in sticking to the
rules
and following facts that may sound
obvious
but it is really important that means
staying out of each other's houses
it means abiding by travel restrictions
it means keeping a safe distance from
people in other households
and it means following all of the
hygiene advice really
really strictly if you have been letting
your guard
down which given what we have all lived
under
now for so long might be understandable
please lift your guard again
it is as important now as it was back in
february and march that we follow
all of that advice very very strictly
secondly in order to reduce the risk of
more of this strain being imported into
scotland we intend to maintain
a strict travel ban between scotland and
the rest of the uk
unfortunately and i am genuinely sorry
about this
that ban will remain in place right
throughout
the festive period we simply cannot risk
more of this new strain
entering the country if we can possibly
avoid it
that means people from scotland not
visiting other parts of the uk and vice
versa
cross-border travel for all but the most
essential purposes
is not permitted we're also asking
pre-scotland and
transport operators to consider how the
enforcement of this
can be strengthened in the period ahead
though of course how that is done
is an operational matter for the chief
constable
we'll also be reviewing urgently over
the next day or so the position on
international travel and i will update
on that
early next week but in the meantime my
strong advice continues to be against
non-essential foreign travel
thirdly we have already advised that
we're possible people should celebrate
christmas
at home in their own household and meet
with others
outdoors only the five day flexibility
from the 23rd to the 27th
of december was planned to recognize the
impact of loneliness and
the difficulty i know we all feel in
leaving loved ones
alone over christmas however earlier
this week we
advised that people should meet indoors
with other households if at all
on no more than one day over the five
day period
given the concern we now have about this
new strain we
now intend to change the law to allow
indoor mixing in a bubble on christmas
day
only from midnight or a minute past
midnight on christmas day to
at midnight going into boxing day
in large parts of england as the prime
minister has just
announced that will not even be allowed
we will allow christmas day to go ahead
but as we have said from the start only
use this flexibility
if you really truly need to this new
strain makes that message all the more
important
our advice is still not to meet indoors
even on christmas day with other
households
if you can possibly avoid it if you have
people traveling to join you for
christmas from elsewhere in the uk that
will no longer
be permitted equally it will no longer
be permitted
for any of us to travel to anywhere in
the rest of the uk for christmas
we simply cannot take the risk of this
strain
traveling from different parts of the uk
if you decide to travel within scotland
that will be allowed on christmas day
only if you can't make it there and back
on the same day please don't go
and we're asking you not even to do that
unless
you feel there is genuinely no
alternative finally on christmas day the
household limits will still apply
as we had set out for the five-day
period a maximum of eight people from
three households will be the law
but again our advice will be to minimise
those numbers as much as possible
standing here saying this um
actually it makes me want to cry as i'm
sure listening to it will make many of
you want to cry
because i know how harsh this sounds um
i know how unfair it is
but this virus is unfair it doesn't care
about christmas it doesn't care about
anything other
than spreading itself as far and wide as
possible
and it has just become unfortunately a
lot better at doing that
now one other point i want to make if
you have caring responsibilities
you can as has always been the case
still visit somebody else and travel
to do that on any day if it is essential
to provide care or assistance to a
vulnerable person that
will not change but for everyone else my
message is please
stay home and stay safe this christmas
that is
in your own interest and in the interest
of everybody you love
now beyond christmas because of this new
strain we also
need to make some changes and this is my
fourth point
today to limit as far as we can the risk
of this strain spreading further than it
has within scotland
we intend to apply level four measures
to
all of mainland scotland for a period of
three weeks
from one minute after midnight on boxing
day morning
the exceptions to that will be orkney
shetland and the western isles and the
other island communities where we have
reduced restrictions in recent weeks
these
areas will go to level three with strict
restrictions on who can travel
to and from them all of these levels
will be reviewed after
two weeks to be clear that means that
from boxing
day morning so this includes boxing day
non-essential shops will close as well
pubs cafes and restaurants takeaway food
will
continue to be allowed finally
since this summer we have been
determined to keep schools open and that
remains our determination as far as we
possibly can
and we've asked people adults to bear a
greater burden of restrictions so that
we can afford to keep pupils in our
classrooms
the situation of this new strain though
means that
until we are sure we have that firmly
under control until we are
sure that we are not facing the same
situation as in the south of england or
wales
we must slightly change our plans for
how schools will operate
after the christmas period schools will
still open next week
and will close on schedule as previously
planned we are not
changing that they were then due to
reopen from the 5th of january with all
council areas back by the 7th of january
instead of that here is what we are now
going to do for the children of key
workers
nurses in our hospitals for example
schools will open and stay open as
previously scheduled
they will also open as normal for the
most vulnerable children
all teachers will also return to work as
scheduled and as planned
however for the majority of pupils the
holiday period will be extended until
the 11th
of january and starting on that date
learning will be online
until at least the 18th of january after
that
assuming we are confident we have the
virus under control
we will aim to reopen schools at fully
but at least until the 18th of january
schools will go
online only other than for the children
of key workers and
the most vulnerable
thank you for bearing with me i'm going
to ask the chief medical officer and
the national clinical director to say a
word or two after me
um but i've taken a bit of time to set
all of this out because i know how
difficult this is and that's
where i want to conclude i know this is
difficult because it's christmas i know
it's difficult because
it is involving greater restrictions for
a period
after christmas and i know it is also
difficult because right now
as of now our case numbers look as if
they are
not as bad as elsewhere and therefore i
understand
that people will be thinking is this
necessary please believe me when i tell
you
with every fiber of my being i would not
be standing here
on the saturday before christmas
announcing this if i did not think
this was necessary i have spent
as all of you have many anxious and
worried days
over the course of the past 10 months
but i've really felt
more worried since much earlier in the
year
as i have today if we don't act now
firmly and decisively this new strain
is transmitting so quickly that it will
very quickly
overwhelm us i want to do everything i
can
to reduce that possibility and that is
why
these very difficult but very necessary
measures are being outlined
today i briefed the leaders of the
opposition parties earlier on i will set
out to parliament as
as and when the presiding officer thinks
that it is necessary but i didn't want
it to leave any time before setting out
to you the public
at what these plans are particularly
given
the proximity to christmas i know how
difficult a christmas this is
was always going to be but now in
particular it will be even more
difficult i am
genuinely sorry about that but we must
take care
collectively to stop this virus
overwhelming us to keep ourselves and
our loved ones stay
safe and stop people dying unnecessarily
and therefore i ask you to bear with us
as we try to
navigate our way through this next
difficult stage
of this pandemic my final point is this
i've said a couple of times in recent
weeks that there is a light in fact i've
said many times in recent weeks that
there is a light at the end of the
tunnel
there is a light at the end of the
tunnel it has not gone out the
vaccination program will pick up pace as
we go into
january but i've also said that there
will be times because we are still in
this pandemic
where the light will be difficult to see
that's the stage we're at right now we
can't see the light at the moment it's
obscured
because of this difficult phase but it
hasn't gone out it is still there we do
have brighter times ahead
but in order to get us safely or as
safely as possible to those brighter
times
i need to ask you for more sacrifices
for a period
thank you so much for listening the
chief medical officer is going to say a
few words
then the national clinical director and
then we are going to take some questions
from journalists
as normal so the uk is one of the most
sophisticated programs of genomic
surveillance
anywhere in the world for covert 19.
between about 5 and 10
of all viral isolates in the uk are
subjected to genomic sequencing so we
can learn more about the virus
and the way that it behaves and the uk
accounts for about 120
000 of the known genomes of this virus
that are available
on the worldwide database since we
learned about this new variant of the
coronavirus on monday there's been a
huge amount of work
underway to understand its behaviors and
its characteristics more clearly
nerve tag which is the uk clinical
committee that considers threats posed
by viruses
like sars cov2 considered the available
evidence and data
around this just yesterday the viruses
of all kinds mutate
commonly when those mutations occur
there are three broad considerations
that need to be examined more closely
what does the mutation mean for
transmission of the virus what does the
mutation mean for the severity of the
disease associated
with the virus and what does the
mutation mean for the pre-existing
immunity
vaccine and treatments and jason will
say a little bit more
about the latter in a second but i want
to concentrate the first two elements
here
there is no moderate to high confidence
in the evidence that this variant of
coronavirus is associated
with a higher degree of transmission as
the first minister says that appears to
be
up to about 70 increase in the
transmissibility
associated with this by a particular
variant
in simple terms it appears to be able to
spread more easily
than the virus that we've become used to
over the last 10 months
there's been a very rapid rise in these
cases in the southeast of england
and in london for this variant has now
become the dominant strain
it appears to have seeded widely beyond
this concentration of cases in the south
of england
so it's also been detected in smaller
numbers elsewhere in england
and the rest of the uk nations too
it's plausible and perhaps likely that
this variant has contributed to this
rapid rising cases being seen across the
southern part of england just now
at present there is no evidence of
change
in the pattern of disease or the
symptoms that are associated with this
variant of the virus
doesn't appear to lead to more severe
disease and it doesn't appear to be
associated with a higher
mortality however it's still very early
in the analysis of this and further work
will continue to assess the impact on
those who are infected by this variant
over the coming days and weeks the uk
cmos have alerted the who to this
mutation
scientists will continue to make further
analysis of it to learn more about its
behaviors and characteristics
in the meantime is more vital than ever
that the public takes steps to limit
transmission in their area
to follow the advice and to continue to
use facts to reduce
their own chances of becoming infected
at any time
jason thank you so there are
three fundamental clinical
considerations as a result of the
science that gregor has just
outlined vaccination testing and
treatment
the virus is presently being grown and
tested at the porter down facility in
england for all of the uk countries
to help us understand exactly what is
going on we know
that this particular strain has 20 new
mutations
within it the virus has changed but our
fundamental methods of fighting back
have stayed the same we need much more
work but
as of december the 19th for now the
vaccination
works the test works and our limited
treatments for those with severe illness
work but the most important fact is that
your behavior
works the way you protect yourself and
your loved ones
hasn't changed everything we know about
infectious disease
is that prevention is always the right
answer
every time you leave home act as if you
are infectious
and act as if you have this new variant
that transmits more easily
wear a face covering avoid crowds clean
your hands and surfaces regularly
keep distanced and self-isolate if you
have symptoms
first minister thanks gregor and jason
we'll move now
to questions from journalists i know
many will be on tight deadlines so we'll
go through them
as quickly as possible glenn campbell
from the bbc
first minute you were never keen on
easing restrictions
over the christmas period with hindsight
do you wish
you hadn't bothered no i mean i've
always agonised over this and and you
know that
from the moment we announced relaxations
for
all the reasons we set out i've advised
against using them
unless absolutely essential because in
my view they were only ever there
for the in recognition of the fact that
some people would find it impossible to
leave loved ones alone
if it wasn't for what i've been told
today about this new strain
i would not be standing here changing uh
from what i said earlier in the week
when we we refreshed the guidance and
tightened
the guidance it is this new strain that
says to me we cannot afford
uh to have that degree of relaxation
even if we're advising people against it
that is why we are reducing
any ability to meet indoors with people
in another household to christmas day
only
and but my advice just as it was earlier
in the week is
think even if that is necessary if you
can get through this christmas in your
own home with your own household that is
the safest thing
to do and that is my very strong advice
as far as possible
and if you do meet with others for
christmas day try and do it
outdoors rather than indoors what we
face right now is a really
really significant threat and we have to
act appropriately and accordingly
ryan maher from stv
thank you first minister we were only we
are only days away from what was meant
to be the start of the relaxation period
and with many people already having
booked her travel from around the uk to
come back to scotland
first of all how willing do you believe
people will be in adhering to these new
guidelines and what would you say to
those that may be thinking
of still breaking these restrictions
thanks
ryan um the travel restrictions uh that
will be in place over
the course of the christmas period just
as they are generally right now will be
in law they're not guidelines they are
the law
so the law will say that throughout this
period it is not permitted to travel
from scotland
to the rest of the uk or vice versa and
that is harsh and i recognize that but
it is necessary
and similarly the travel restrictions
that apply in scotland right now
not to travel in and out of if you live
in a level three area not to leave your
own local authority
area and if you live elsewhere in
scotland not to travel into a local
authority area
apart from on christmas day when you
will be allowed to travel
to if you think it necessary but only
within that 24
hour period apart from that these travel
restrictions will stay in place and of
course
uh the vast majority of the country from
saturday will be in level four and
therefore it will not be permitted to
travel
in and out of your own local authority
area if you are in
at the level four area and the other
parts of the country will be in level
three so for the next
three weeks after boxing day the travel
restrictions that are in law
will be uh pretty severe because we
think that is necessary to limit the
spread
of this virus generally but in
particular this new strain of it
jim matthews from skye
thanks very much first minister can you
expand on what you had to say about this
new strain of the virus
in hospitals and in care homes
and let me ask you about you know it's
often held up as the
uh example that we speak about when it
comes to christmas and reuniting
families
uh the grandmother or grandfather living
alone
separated uh from their loved ones their
presence will be bought
their travel plans might be already made
what do you say to them
when they think well you know i'm
committed i'm going to do it whatever i
hear today from our first minister
and what do you so what do you say to
them and what will happen to them
if they make that journey um thanks uh
for that i'm going to hand over to
gregor and jason to expand on what i
will say
about care homes and hospitals um i'll
very briefly
address that and i should say we require
to do further analysis
in order to be definitive one way or the
other about what i'm about to say is
actually the case but one of the things
so there's two two aspects there's one
of the things we have been
uh puzzling over if that's not too
frivolous award actually
stressing over in recent weeks is the
fact that we have
many fewer care homes than we did
earlier in the year that have
outbreaks but what we have been
witnessing is a phenomenon that when a
care home has an outbreak it appears to
be infecting
more people within that care home than
perhaps previously was the case and
we've been struggling to understand that
it may be that it is not this faster
transmitting virus that is
responsible but of course this now does
raise the question in our minds
is that the case and there will be
genomic sequencing work done to try to
help us answer that question
on hospitals we have seen over the past
few days
a rapidly deteriorating situation in the
borders of scotland
which seems to have started within a
melrose hospital and so
again the question has raised been
raised in our minds
is that a factor is this new strain a
factor there and what appears to have
been
a rapidly developing nosocomial hospital
infection but gregor and jason will be
able to give you perhaps a little bit
more on that
um my message to people who were
planning to travel
uh you know obviously there is the
ability uh
fairly tight uh within fairly tight
limits to do that on christmas day i'm
advising not to
unless you really feel it's essential
and my message to everybody is firstly i
am
i'm desperately sorry i you know it
breaks my heart to be standing here
saying these things
as i know there will be heartbroken
people listening to this right now
but this is i hope once in a century
pandemic
that we just have to get through as
safely as possible
and anybody who is thinking about
mixing with another household traveling
to do that you're putting yourself at
risk and you're putting people you love
at risk
and perhaps raising the prospect of
having loved ones that are not still
with us when we do get to the other side
of this and i know
that's really hard but that is what we
are living in just now and we have to
i think really uh just hunker down
and get through this as much as possible
i used i don't want to get all
literature focused i use a quote from
sheamus heaney the irish poet um
in parliament a couple of weeks ago
which is uh
if i'm getting it absolutely correctly
if we winter this one out we can summer
anywhere
and that's the spirit we should be
trying to use to get through this right
now
obviously the police will enforce travel
restrictions that are in place is for
the police to
determine operationally how they do that
people can have fixed penalty notices if
they are breaching
travel restrictions but as people to
abide by them to keep themselves and
their loved ones safe
so the uk laws and senior clinicians
across the uk have been in fairly close
contact over the last few days we've
been speaking at least a couple of times
a day
in relation to what we are finding out
about this new variant and one of the
features that we are seeing in other
parts
of the uk is quite a strong signal
coming as part of that
nosocomial infection so that may be in
hospitals or it may be
in other institutions such as care homes
one of the features
that we become concerned about is the
rate of spread
and that we've seen in some of the
institutions in scotland and so
i mentioned the genomic sequencing at
the start of my statement one of the
things that we can do is to be able to
take isolates
of the virus from those facilities and
subject them to genomic sequencing to
see
if there is any links back to this
particular variant that might explain
why um the the virus has or why the
infection has reacted in such a strong
way in some of these environments jason
you might want to see a little bit more
about the border situation
so in nhs borders we were consent in the
main
around the whole of the uk the
healthcare associated infections have
followed community transmission rates
that's how it's worked up or down there
appears to be
something that has happened in borders
that seems to step beyond that beyond
the community transmission
that may just be random but we want to
check it's important for the public to
realize though
genomic sequencing is not quick it
doesn't help us in real time
it helps us unfortunately only
retrospectively because it takes quite a
lot of time in the laboratory
so we will find out but it doesn't help
us today what helps us today
is people restricting their behavior
thank you very much um first minister
first of all just on that quote if we
winter now we can summer anywhere
for a long time people in scotland have
been hearing the same thing if we
sacrifice now
things will pick up and there was a lot
of focus on act now to save christmas
and i just wonder if first of all what
you can tell those people who are
starting to really really feel
demoralized that it's just one thing
after another after another
and that lockdowns are not working we
don't have a lid on this through
lockdowns
the second question is about the again
that obviously this strain that you're
talking about is extremely concerning
um why then are we not looking down
immediately schools only have two maybe
three days left before they're going to
close down anyway
that's a lot of mixing a lot of kids
going back to see grandparents on
christmas day
um what can i say to people are feeling
demoralized um i don't expect this to
make anybody feel better but i share
that i'm not i'm not apart from this i'm
having to take these horrible decisions
and
announce them to you but you know i i'm
impacted by them as well i
share that sense of fatigue and
demoralization about this we are we're
living through a global pandemic
the only other thing i would say and i
don't expect it to make people feel
better immediately is that we're not
alone
we're not alone in the uk and we're not
alone across europe
you see countries france germany the
netherlands
many other countries right now have
ahead of us
imposed further really strict lockdowns
because they understand
as we do that we cannot allow this fire
is just to run
rampant and take control of us in terms
of lockdowns are not working i don't
want us to be locked down and we have
actually avoided another national
lockdown
up until now although much of the
country will be in level four again
come saturday but i would say and and
you know this is perhaps a little bit
different different in scotland it is in
some parts of england not all of england
and some parts of wales
if it wasn't for this new strain i
wouldn't be standing here right now
announcing this because our case levels
right now
because of the levels approach we've
taken are actually
quite stable this is preventative action
because we know there is a
a more rapidly transmitting strain out
there
and so we're acting preventatively and
everything we've learned about this
virus
it says that you do that you act quickly
and don't have regrets later and that's
what we're seeking to do but the the
second question is why not just right
now
and that is because this is preventative
in scotland we
we we're not in that really difficult
situation that london is just now so we
can uh
take this on not a slow basis but a
slightly more phased basis over the next
few days what has been announced for the
prime minister for the south of england
what i know mark drakeford
has been announced for wales these are
parts of the country that already have
case levels
much much higher than we have right now
so although we have to act quickly
and decisively we are still trying to be
as proportionate
as we we possibly can it's not never an
easy
balance to get right but we are seeking
to do that as carefully
as we can all right louis warner for my
team we're just going to leave
the first minister's news conference
there but i'll just pick up and follow
on from what she was talking about there
she set out these new measures for
scotland but insisted that they are
mainly preventative
rather than in comparison to uh london
the south east england
and wales being reactive to a worsening
situation she said the situation in
scotland is not as severe
as in other places in the uk they have a
small number of cases of this new
variant we've been hearing about today
that she said they'd identified in
scotland
she said officially 17 but that is
probably an underestimate
um but essentially the changes in
scotland are that
the household bubble mixing that had
originally been planned for five days is
only going to apply
on christmas day itself so that matches
up with what the welsh government had
announced and tiers one two and three in
england
as of boxing day uh midnight on boxing
day
as at the end of christmas day all of
scotland is going to go
all of mainland scotland is going to go
into level four
the highest tier uh the only the
highland uh only the islands
uh shetland shetland orkney and the
island communities will be spared
that so very strict uh if
pretty much lockdown measures coming in
for scotland as of boxing day
and crucially a difference on schools as
well the scottish government said
they're determined to keep schools open
but nicolas sturgeon said
they'll still close on schedule this
coming week but they will not open as
normal on the 5th of january
they'll only open for key workers
children
on the 5th of january after christmas
but the majority of pupils will be on
holiday until the 11th of january
and they'll be learning online until at
least the 18th of january she said
we hope to uh reopen normally after that
depending on the situation but nicolas
surgeons
sturgeon striking a pretty downbeat tone
as we've heard from both the welsh first
minister and the prime minister earlier
today
uh things are not looking good let's
bring in our scotland correspondent
james matthews
james i was just saying there nicholas
sturgeon making the point she believes
these are preventative
which is different from what's happening
um in wales northern ireland
and in england but still as a boxing day
tough restrictions for scotland
yeah tom i think you've covered it very
comprehensively you've run through
exactly what scotland's first minister
had to say point by point
uh it is in line with what's happening
elsewhere in the uk clearly there was a
four nations call earlier today and she
says
that it makes her want to cry listening
to what she had to say
during that news conference but as you
said it's broadly in line
with what we see elsewhere in the uk
that five day window
over christmas has been reduced to uh
the one day there are a number of
aspects to it all peculiar to scotland
um
travel is allowed within scotland uh on
christmas day there is still a maximum
of eight people
allowed to gather but
she said that uh there shouldn't be
travel
between the rest of the united kingdom
and scotland in either direction
and we need to double check what the
legal status is of that but
if that is a legal rule being laid down
then that would be
uh unique i think in the in the context
of this and indeed in
recent history so um yeah quite a number
of things
uh to come out of that scottish
government news conference but broadly
in line with what we've heard
elsewhere in the uk she said there will
be tier four restrictions
after christmas day that's not happening
immediately because
of the numbers for this new strain as
you said there are 17 known cases
but she reckons that is an underestimate
so
it's not as high as it is elsewhere in
the uk this new strain she thinks
that we are still very much in a
preventative stage in terms of stopping
its spread
so there is she would have it some
wriggle room some space for scotland to
uh
to delay further restrictions after
christmas day
yeah james thanks james matthews uh
listening to that news conference and
also was asking questions of the first
minister
um so just to reiterate key points
they're uh changing the law in scotland
indoor mixing of households on christmas
day only three households a maximum of
eight people
and nicolas sturgeon said even then only
if you really have to do it and as james
said
at that travel ban which we think is
going to be in law between scotland and
the uk
and i think nicolas sturgeon said it's
for the police to decide
how to enforce that but she did say in
law and to scotland um taking
a rather strict line in terms of travel
in and out of the country and will be
locking down
like much of the rest of the uk as of
boxing day
boris johnson then earlier today
canceled christmas for millions of
families in london
the east and the south east the prime
minister announced that new
tough tier four restriction with no
household mixing allowed
in those affected areas as we've been
hearing a new strain of coronavirus
is spreading much faster but the chief
medical officer earlier said that there
was no evidence
that it was making people more sick